THERE'S ANY MORE FOLLOW-UPS, I
CAN DO THAT.
NEIL: I HEAR THAT.
OUT OF EAGLE PASS, TEXAS, THE
LIEUTENANT CHRIS, HE TELLS IT
LIKE IT IS, TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I CAUGHT THAT FROM BETO
O'ROURKE AND I TRY NOT TO PLAY
POLITICS ON THIS SHOW.
THAT'S A NUMBERS GAMES HERE.
IF YOU HAVE BUSES SHIPPED OUT
OF EL PASO BY A DEMOCRATIC
MAYOR AND ANGRY ABOUT THAT KIND
OF THING OUT OF GOVERNOR
ABBOTT.
YOU SHOULD BE ANGRY NO MATTER
WHAT THE BUS OR WHO IS
COMMISSIONING THEM, SHOULDN'T
YOU?
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
NEIL.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT EL PASO HAS
SEEN A MASSIVE SURGE IN
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
AVERAGING 1500 A DAY AND NEVER
EXPERIENCED THAT BEFORE.
NOT ONLY THAT, NEIL, WE TALK
ABOUT CRUEL AND HUMANE
TREATMENT OF THE MIGRANTS, SOME
OF THEM ARE SLEEPING IN THE
STREETS IN TENTS.
ADULTS AND KIDS AND NOTHING,
THERE'S NO OUTCRY, AND NO
OUTRAGE FROM THE OFFICIALS IN
REGARDS TO THAT.
BUT YET, WHEN TEXAS AND AGAIN,
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS, TOO
EARLIER THIS WEEK, WHEN TEXAS
IS BUSING FROM MIGRANTS TO THE
SANCTUARY CITIES, THAT IT'S A
PROBLEM.
THE MIGRANTS ARE TREATED
FAIRLY, AS FAR AS WITHIN THE
LAW, TRANSPORTING THE MIGRANTS
FROM TEXAS TO THE SANCTUARY
CITIES AND GETTING GOOD
TREATMENT ONCE THEY GET TO THE
SANCTUARY CITIES, BUT AGAIN,
YOU CANNOT COMPARE APPLES AND
ORANGES, AS FAR AS WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND EL PASO IS DOING, IF
WE'RE GOING TO CRITICIZE ONE
PARTY WE'RE GOING TO CRITICIZE
ONE, WE'LL CRITICIZE AS A
WHOLE.
NEIL: AGAIN, YOU AND I TRIED TO
SKEW THE WHOLE POLITICS, BUT
THIS IS COMING FROM A MAYOR PRO
TEM IN EAGLE PASS TALKING ABOUT
THIS PROBLEM.
THIS IS FROM THE DEMOCRAT.
>> I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING,
YOU'RE NOT BEING LIED TO.
YOU RUN INTO THEM AT THE GAS
STATION AND THEY TELL YOU, I
WANT TO GO FURTHER UP NORTH.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'LL
AT.
THEY'LL SAY HOW FAR IS SAN
ANTONIO, HOW FAR IS HOUSTON.
HOW FAR IS NEW YORK.
NEIL: IT'S A CRISIS, BOTTOM
LINE, IT'S A CRISIS AND YOU'VE
BEEN SAYING THAT AND NOW OF
COURSE, WE HAVE THE DEA WANTING
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
FENTANYL PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S A
CRISIS, BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE BORDER THAT'S CREATING THE
FENTANYL CRISIS IS NOT A BORDER
OR A CRISIS.
I'M AT A LOSS.
>> WELL, I MEAN, WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT EVERYTHING WE'VE BEEN
DOING AS FAR AS THE STATE OF IF
TEXAS AND WHAT GOVERNOR ABBOTT
IS DOING SIGNING AN ORDER FOR
THE MEXICAN CARTEL, AND NOW
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO, AS FAR AS IF
THEY'RE GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE IF
THEY'RE TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS
AND MANUFACTURING THE DAILY
POISON THAT IS KILLING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR AND NOT ONLY THAT,
NOW THE RAINBOW COLORED
FENTANYL COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER, AS HALLOWEEN
APPROACHES, ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE TO DO IS PARENTS IS
EDUCATE AND SPREAD AWARENESS TO
OUR CHILDREN BECAUSE, AGAIN,
THIS POISON THAT'S PLAGUING OUR
COUNTRY AND NOT DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
WE CAN DO WHAT WE CAN AS A
STATE TO GO AFTER THE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
GO IN AND PUT PRESSURE ON
MEXICO TO STOP THE POISON FROM
ENTERI